aisa is with us in atlanta hi ASA how
are you I'm good they thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up I have a question
regarding how to give advice to my
sister she hasn't made the best life
decisions and the latest decision that
she made was getting behind on our car
payment and her car recently got
possessed she's a single mom living at
home with my parents she's 27 years old
and I've given her your book the Total
Money Makeover I've helped her you know
budget her money and I just really want
her to get on the right path and I want
to know what happened when you helped
her budget the money and gave her the
Total Money Makeover book did she do any
of it she didn't read the book I know
she did and I'm not sure fees and
although it is because I gave it that to
her for Christmas
and I just recently helped her budget
like last week I just don't know she's
going to listen to anything that I tell
her any advice nothing more painful than
having people you love be stupid is her
right it's hard when people you love her
stupid it's only because you sounds like
you want her to straighten up more and
she wants to straighten up I really do I
really really do hmm
but it doesn't sound like she wants it
very bad it doesn't seem like it it's
like she'll get you know she'll try to
get herself on the right path and then
something will happen or just lose that
she's 27
[Music]
what does she make a year to Yavanna no
but I know it's not a lot because she
hasn't finished her bachelor's degree
yet well you can make good money without
a bachelor's degree in some cases oh
yeah well I think the thing you need to
do is try to figure out why she's
unmotivated is it because she's lazy or
because she doesn't have hope and what I
would do is just sit and ask her some
questions and try to find out where her
heart is you can you know you know you
can lead a horse to water but you can't
make them drink you cannot make people
behave you know I've got people I love I
can't make them behave and I'm Dave
Raymond you
yeah you just can't they're going to do
what they're going to do so if she needs
some hope and you can show her some
stuff like you did with the budget and
show some stuff you've done in your life
maybe that would give her hope and maybe
that would give her a fire under her
butt and get her moving you know but if
she's just being lazy if she just being
a goof off you know she's just going to
continue to experience painting until
she figures out that doesn't water and
that's a process for it so I'm sorry
she's facing that but I would just love
her if you want to put her through
Financial Peace University you could do
that but it won't work unless she's
ready to work hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]